welcome for the very first time someone
I've known for quite some time because
our children go to school together and I
don't know if that's the inspiration of
me being on the next episode of I'm
sorry on truTV season two going on loved
this person's work way before actually
met her and veep and Curb Your
Enthusiasm and stepbrothers and so much
more good to see you Andrea Savage
having me so let's talk about my acting
ability yeah no no let's definitely get
into the most important part of the it's
not like we won't find out on Sunday
who's in the Super Bowl will to place
that aside great because there's larger
issues in my acting ability yeah and I
feel like we'll probably talk about it
through now through Sunday cuz there's a
lot to get into yes I will say and I
hate to admit it you were very natural
and good what do you hate because I'd
love to sit here and be like it was
awful and it took me hours in the Edit
room just to make it palatable because
it almost was if English was not your
first language yes but you actually were
not you actually were very natural and
it was really good well it's funny
because you you came up to me a couple
months before and you're like look
there's a scene where we're at a
birthday party and by the way is based
on a true story this actually happened
yes so this actually happened it was in
preschool and my daughter we were
leaving a party and they gave out fish
in a bag and those fish do not live a
long time so the entire preschool class
within 24 hours was dealing with every
single kid's pet dying and literally
just we had to start explaining death to
our four-year-olds because this you're
on a live show but I appreciate that
sorry that's okay I usually ask if I can
swear and I forgot so I tend to swear oh
good this terrible bag of fish and
literally the whole class shut down like
no parents weren't sleeping their kids
were up all night because kids within 20
minutes or like this is my best friend
this is my pet this is my fish and they
all died so basically the loot bag was
difficult parenting issues for you to
have to deal with
the whole preschool class shut down
because of this gift bag of fish so we
wrote it in and I think it was actually
my husband's idea he was like you know
you should have give the fish it's rich
because in the episode the whole time
well now I know I can't swear but you do
say through the whole thing
blanking Rich Eisen through the whole
episode we swear and we're so just like
this guy that would be hilarious you
know it's so funny that you know when
when you I first received the script
which you wrote right yes okay no well I
room write everything with everyone mr.
Johnson has the writing crap but we the
whole room right okay so the script
comes and of course you know I'll be
honest you flip to see how many lines
and flipy came as a PDF so I hit the
search you're the find find my last name
in there and I saw I was in one scene
but then my name kept coming up
throughout the rest of the entire
episode with an f-bomb in front of my
name each time and I turned to my wife
who you know very well as well and I'm
like how do I not do this this is
fantastic
yeah well I'm curse to the entire the
entire time and I do coin the phrase of
the Rich Eisen boner because Tom Scott
who I know you've had a couple times
here and he's very into fantasy football
right couldn't be less interested on my
side but he in the show we have him
really just like having pretty big crush
on you and I always like your rich eyes
and boners showing and so I feel like
that's gonna take off so get ready well
that could be fantasy football names
throughout the entire universe eyes away
I'm just saying Andrea you know you
might be starting something here I would
be Andrew savage here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so do you remember how hot it
was it was 120 degrees I was directing I
direct this episode and do you remember
the camera started melting yes we had
stopped shooting the camera started
melting we had to put them in AC tubes
to to cool them down and the camera guys
shoes were melting off the sidewalk was
awful they melted it was
on the hottest day of the year I've
never been more hot and with you
you couldn't you can't tell well you
were also handed out popsicles there was
it was wonderful it was really is a
great environment and like I told you
everybody there was so nice and so
absolutely great
so you're seeing you're not a fantasy
football person at all right I am NOT
tom will start talking about it and I
play in a poker league where guys type
and I'm just literally they started
talking I just go I'm gonna be honest I
don't care nor anything that's coming
out of your mouth I'm not interested I
haven't again we need to keep it clean I
have I have played poker with you yes
you have and you are I think we did this
at some this by the way this sounds like
a potential episode of it okay so I
think either was with your husband with
you because you know our kids go to
school together and this is one of those
retreats so yeah it got down to the
point where the parents grabbed we
grabbed these sugar packets around the
table it was it was tough times now did
we did we ascribe actual American
currency to the sugar packets I actually
happened by the way Andrew savage is
you're a savage poker player thank you
by the way that is a compliment thank
you
I knew it was compliment I took it as
well how long did you play poker I've
played for about I think it's 14 years
give or take like an out like two hours
how's your played in the World Series
well I have played in the World Series
of Poker
I've never played in the main event but
I played in different events there I've
once I've never won a bracelet or
anything like that but I've won some
bigger tournaments in Vegas I my game
has not gone well the past two and a
half years because I've been under a
rock so I play very little and now when
I play I'm like oh I'm terrible but I
can hold my own
by the way I say here on the show when
when you go higher register it's when
you're really trying to tell the truth
right there you're trying to you're
trying to be really humble about it but
you just want higher register
I find the people la I feel like
people's voices go high when they lie
like if you get a haircut that just
doesn't look great and you're like I got
my haircut is look good more like like I
feel like people go real high damn Isaac
your voice went high your line but I
feel like they go the other way like the
argue or tell are tell here is when
we're like no but see how your voice you
go high register go higher register
that's a telephone so when you gonna
play in the World Series of Poker like
the main event let me get out there you
know what's weird I I think the main
event again I was about to swear is a
little bit it's too many people it's
it's like playing the lottery I'd rather
play a smaller tournament where people
are a little bit more focused like 1500
people versus 8,000 people you get two
bad beats you're done like and it's
$10,000 so you think you're dead money
walking in there is that what you saying
dead dead money woman walking walking in
there come on now
I don't know luck I feel like start
until it gets deeper in I feel like luck
starts to be more of it versus scale and
I think poker people are like oh it's
gambling poker is very much a game of
skill and over time if you're good you
will come up ahead but I like to hedge
my bets and have it be where the luck
and the skill are a little bit closer
and I feel like the main event just luck
has to play too big of a portion in it
especially near the beginning now do
would you see any day if you go there
would you would you wear like the
wraparound shades or the hoodie and the
earbuds and all that service I will say
uh no I like to be out I don't wear a
sunglass I'm just like Here I am
look at me yeah look at my face decide
what's happening inside what's happening
yeah I used to take my wedding ring off
though okay now yeah when I would play
poker my husband knew - was it because
it's all men and I found that they would
play differently with you and I could
figure out how they were playing against
me if they didn't think I'm if they were
like I don't know I don't want to I
don't want to knock her out I don't want
to keep her around the table so you can
kind of use that to your advantage you
think that guys playing poker with you
Andrew savage if they think they've got
a shot at the title they're not going to
be as aggressive
earlier rounds the earlier rounds about
to say there's a huge pot in the earlier
rounds where everyone's just kind of
chatting and that kind of stuff yeah so
do you do do you check raise with your
your your non ringed hand do you use
that to your advantage where I was like
looking at my cards with my left hand
more than my right although that is the
can that I do look at so you know it's
just like you're chit-chatting and
there's there's you know especially back
then there weren't a lot of women there
and so I think it was like oh well we're
not gonna they'd be like I would call
but you know what forget it you're easy
on the eyes kid yeah then you're like
yeah alright I fold my pocket aces
honestly yeah
Andrew savage here on the Rich Eisen
show how you enjoying truTV
I'm sorry season two it's just it's as
funny as ever I'm seeing also the tweet
sent your way where people are so fired
up ready I'm waiting for people to turn
on me because I have the nicest fans in
the whole world people seem to really
like just like the show and it seems to
like I think what it is is it shows like
a marriage that people actually like
each other and I think more people have
happy marriages than we like to talk
about and you only see people who hate
each other on TV and in movies or
they're sick of each other and the guys
like my wife won't have sex with me and
the wife is like oh it's like a third
child and so I think in all the
relationships everyone kind of like
seach other and I think people like it
but it has an edge and we talk about a
lot of dirty staff yes you do you know
cubes and I can you know just just the
cubes just stick yeah yeah this is a
family audience Andrew this is false TV
you're on truTV this is faulty that's
the opposite of whatever yeah it's been
going great and I'm really proud of this
season and we've got a lot we have
amazing guest stars we have an amazing
cast on the show other than Rich Eisen
which obviously Top Billing I appreciate
you saying them but you know we got
Jason Mantzoukas back we have Adam Scott
was in last night's or two nights ago
episode he played my gynecologist
which was a real story of when my
husband and I were at my doctor actually
was when I was pregnant and my real
doctor wasn't there so I had this back
the backup doctor and my husband
realized when they walked in they were
like oh my god Jeremy that they hug they
he was his camp counselor the doctor and
they proceeded to chitchat while the guy
is in stop you get it they're chatting
about whether or not they've
reconstructed the dock at the camp then
he's like how's your sister oh my god
honey his sister was my first kiss and
I'm like uh-huh and and you're being
worked on and worked on right there just
chit-chatting away as if they bumped
into each other at the bar you know it's
it's theirs when when you're I guess
you're a professional it doesn't you
know dawn on you I've had yes I had
Chris Mullin one of the best basketball
players of my youth at Saint John's you
big huge NBA players he in the Hall of
Fame Chris Mullin I would think so yeah
well he should be she get in I never met
him before
I didn't think yeah I know I never met
him before I got to meet I got to meet
him at 8:00 thank you I got to meet him
at a golf tournament Johnson yeah and
warriors
yeah warriors warriors yeah come out and
play flat top but anyway I got a chance
to meet him at a golf tournament yeah
and he was showering and
[Music]
well it's you're done you're done
playing golf and you gotta get ready for
the next you yeah we were showering
before you and white shadow where you're
all in one same shower you're on I mean
if I could just have one afternoon let
me lose injury in the locker rooms
Bronco is Chris Mullen to brag about
taking a shower with Chris Moen
recognized me which surprised me and
then it wanted to have a conversation
right then and there
wearing absolutely nothing and he was
completely what are you wearing a towel
okay because I'm not comfy I'm not used
to just performing showering and talking
to people with nothing on I get it this
season that involves that I have a
strange amount of nudity this season no
kidding
all comedic nudity but the point where
my lawyer was sending me my fourth
nudity writer of the season
hmm and I felt the need to respond like
back like I promise you I keep my
clothes up like I was like he was like
what's going on over there and I was
like none of it's flattering it's all
really uncomfortable awkward new today
but I realized I had written quite a bit
of strange nudity for myself but there
is a thing where I do have a
conversation with someone where they're
just casually and we're both don't have
shirts on and it's very uncomfortable
season two of I'm sorry with Andrea
Savage and Chris Mullen and by the way
every single free-throw that there's
gonna be shot on a game in the NC
double-a tournament there's they'll do
the promo for I'm sorry we'll see that
oh it's nonstop great it'll be all good
for you I can't wait for still Rich
Eisen boner to be next that'll be next
Wednesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
9:00 p.m. Central Time at Andrea savage
on Twitter yes it's great to see you
I'll see you around the schoolyard
exactly with with the goldfish yeah
great to see you congratulations season
two of truTV's I'm sorry at 10 p.m.
Eastern on Wednesday 9 p.m. Pacific the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience